one of country music's biggest names
singer songwriter Miranda Lambert
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna get to the food part but that
is country Superstar Miranda Lambert
Smash Hit kerosene off her debut studio
album back in 2005. she has made quite
the career for herself being honored uh
with dozens of Academy of Country Music
Awards including Entertainer of the Year
in 2022. she's taken home 14 Country
Music Association awards and now here's
the food part she's author of a new
cookbook called y'all eat yet welcome to
the pretty Bitchin Kitchen and standards
has said I can say that word the book is
made up of stories about Lambert's life
particularly the women who helped shape
her and the recipes they've all shared
over the years Miranda Lambert good
morning thank you for being here good
morning uh your song The House That
Built Me is one of my all-time favorites
and this is kind of the recipes that
made you it is this is this is the house
built me in the kitchen in the kitchen
yes absolutely it seems like you you
started writing a memoir and then
started writing a cookbook and then
realized it's actually just one book how
did this come to be yeah it is it's more
of a lifestyle book really honestly it's
it's about Sisterhood and I was lucky
enough to be raised by two generations
of very strong women so I kind of feel
like they shaped who I am as a woman and
as an artist and a lot of those lessons
were learned in the kitchen or around
the table most of our memories started
around the table so it felt just natural
to like put those recipes that really
made me kind of who I am
um all together in a book with a bunch
of stories that I've never told anybody
I know we learned so much I call it
Miranda fun facts you live life on the
Fly you love eating more than cooking
salsa is love in a jar first thing you
bought when you signed a record deal was
a four-wheeler peanut butter and jelly
is the ultimate safety sandwich I so
agree especially if it's Wonder Bread
that's soft yeah it sticks to the roof
of your mouth I love that but you say
this food doesn't solve problems but it
does bring people together because it's
about friendship and comfort and that's
been true your whole life yeah I mean I
definitely think if you think about it
you know some some of the biggest
moments in your life whether it's a
celebration graduation birthday wedding
it's all about the food yeah and if
something terrible happens it's all
about the food so I feel like it's just
a way to show love and food tells a
story I'm a Storyteller you know I'm a
singer-songwriter and I feel like this
is just another extension of
Storytelling on a plate you know you're
so spot on about life lessons being
learned around the kitchen table and you
talk about that quite a bit what are
some life lessons that come to mind that
you hold near and dear I mean all of
them you know some of them I can't ever
say on TV because these women were wild
but
17 I started writing songs and at 17 you
don't have I didn't have like a ton of
life to write about yet and listening to
just these ladies growing up around me
my grandma's generation of girlfriends
and my mom generational girlfriends I
sort of I think my first couple of
really sad songs were not something I
had experienced but something I was
watching my my aunties go through you
know and so it really taught me about
emotion and kind of what to expect
laugh's gonna throw some stuff at you
sometimes and life does oh does it you
said songwriters are only as good as the
people they meet and the stories they
hear what I love is a relationship that
you have with your friends and your mom
and your dad I loved your whole family
by the way I just thought all of them
were so great they're cool but you talk
about they're very cool but you talk
about when you're going through your
divorce you had all these things on your
schedule but life doesn't stop shows
that you book don't stop because you're
going through something bad so you said
when people when you get lemons squeeze
it into a drink and the moment you get
when stuff gets real pick up the phone
don't text call somebody yeah these
women really got you through they did
you know they they raised me and they
they supported me through good bad and
ugly and that's what my group of friends
we call us gen 3 of the Yahya yeah uh we
called our Yaya Sisterhood of traveling
casserole dish
two of the book Miranda is at the listen
I don't cook but when I was listening
looking at the ingredients I thought I
think I could actually make that I'll
tell you it's very approachable these
are very doable we are more about making
it easy so we can spend more time
drinking and hanging than you know all
of the hard stuff yeah no I mean this
really is it's it's a starter book for
someone who has is not yet a home cook
but wants to make this sort of table in
their own home uh you've got a great
brisket recipe just
standards the meatloaf the meatloaf
meatloaf you've got you've got a mashed
potato uh recipe it's just solid can't
go wrong there you know fruit salad uh
what was it like working with these
women in your life to decide what goes
in and then also because everyone's got
a little bit different taste you know
whether the chicken salad has the
Cranberries or not well mom's chicken
salad is a staple and nobody argued that
but it was fun I mean it was also a good
excuse for us to just have happy hours
and decide which recipe should make the
final cut yeah but it was really more
about the stories and what what foods
went with the memories you know stories
and the pictures Miranda yes great
pictures I love looking at pictures of
you as a little girl the stuff that you
used to do in your own life as a cook
yeah I mean not much has changed except
my husband is the cook in our family
yeah you call him the Daredevil in the
kitchen cookbook yeah
I do cook I do cook but Brendan says he
is the cooking yeah yeah why is the
bunny cake so special to you and you
know what I've been making that bunny
cake it's the first picture in the whole
book because it's like you know I made
it I think for the first time in second
grade and I literally make it every
Easter and now yes
um we have a surprise for you our recipe
Baker here Chris Stover he made the
bunny thing he's so cute so uh one you
have to tell us how
Kisses For Eyes of black licorice for
whiskers use and the gumdrops you said
it's all about the decoration when it
comes to this so how did he do he did
amazing it's super fun and like it's a
feel-good thing you know I've I've been
making sauce a little girl I spent like
two Easters ago with my whole band and
crew we had an Easter egg hunt we're all
adults but I made the bunny cake yeah
and my stepson's four and a half and I
make the bunny cake with him now so it's
really it's her tradition this whole
book is about you know carrying on
traditions and making memories so that's
all we have at the end I hope you have
new music coming Miranda because I love
in the story you talk about you and your
mom used to drive to radio stations to
get your music played we did and look at
where you are today you have new music
coming I do I have a couple of really
cool collaborations up my sleeve okay
yeah but I'll come out give us some
initials and when the movie uh
Sisterhood of the Traveling casserole
dish comes out
videos yeah I would love that all right
Miranda Lambert thank you thanks for
having me nice job on the cake Chris so
cute yet is available today wherever you
buy your books get one